some very good news from Maine Maine
residents have approved a ballot
question which will allow voters to rank
their choice of candidates this is
called ranked choice voting it's also
known as Instant Runoff voting and this
is something I've been advocating for
for a very long time any time someone
asks me how can we really make it so
that third parties can have a shot in
what is a two-party monopolistic system
duopoly ranked choice voting is very
very high on the list and under this
overhaul ballots will be counted at the
state level in multiple rounds where the
last place candidates get eliminated
until a candidate wins by a majority so
here's how it could work right uh you
have a situation where you've got I
don't know four candidates and you have
Donald Trump gets forty-eight percent of
the vote and Hillary Clinton gets forty
seven percent of the vote which leaves
five percent and then you have another
candidate that gets three percent of the
vote and another that gets two on the
initial ranking okay last place is two
percent so we're gonna get rid of that
candidate who was the second choice for
the people that voted for that last
place candidate you now credit their
votes to the three remaining candidates
who is last again well okay it's now the
three percent candidate who maybe went
to four percent on round two let's
eliminate them who was their third
choice and maybe at that point we'll
know you would if you only have two
candidates now one of the two remaining
candidates will actually have more than
fifty percent of the vote and one of the
major incentives for this type of system
is that you will actually get winners
who have a majority of the vote you will
end up with winners that have under
fifty percent of the vote but the really
interesting element of this is that it
can make third parties viable because if
you have a lot of people in Maine for
example if they were to do this for the
presidential race right which is a
different question that we're talking
about this will apply to US Senate US
House governor state Senate and state
house not to the press
dential race but if it did you may have
a lot of people who say listen you know
really I like the third party candidate
from the whatever the rent is too damn
high party I really like that guy uh but
I'm worried if I vote for him instead of
uh the person I really don't want coming
in second the person I really don't want
might come in first well it solves it
because you say my number one choice is
the rent is too damn high guy but then
my number two choice is Hillary Clinton
and if rent is too damn high guy does
not have enough votes to remain after
round one then your vote is credited to
Hillary Clinton this is a very good
system Pat yeah I'm totally on board
with it I mean a lot of the times it
seems that we're voting against a
candidate rather right for them and we
really have to get out of this lesser of
two evils mentality and get to a point
where people can just vote their
conscience this will allow that in great
part obviously to really level playing
field we also need to completely
restructure we need a major paradigm
shift in terms of campaign finance and
with citizens united and and the
incoming kleptocracy pluto plutocratic
oligarchy that we're going to be dealing
with under President Donald not
particularly likely to happen but this
is going to be if there is going to be a
change to the two-party status quo in
the United States some version of
Instant Runoff voting is likely going to
be involved in that and I know that it
can seem like okay main passed it for
everything but their presidential
elections this isn't really going to
catalyze change maybe not but remember
the fight for LGBT marriage equality
started with just Massachusetts
something like 13 years ago roughly and
it took awhile for momentum to build and
now we have nationwide same-sex marriage
when it came to cannabis legalization it
started with a few states
decriminalizing and some medical
cannabis etcetera and now we have many
states that have legalized recreational
cannabis yes a lot of it may be undone
by incoming Attorney General sepsis jeff
Sessions we'll deal with that when it
happens but it can start slowly as long
as it's a step in the right direction
that's a really good thing and there's
no doubt this is
in the right direction Pat although we
know who would be against this right the
status quo wouldn't want this because
the status quo is the status quo because
of the system we have now yeah I think
the third parties like the Libertarian
Party in the Green Party would get such
a big boost out of that because when you
look at where people ideologically line
up with which party they do yeah a lot
of the times it's those minor parties
before a big establishment one like the
Republican or democratic party yeah if
you see you line up ninety percent with
a third party and sixty-five percent
with one of the two parties that has a
chance to win most people being
pragmatic are gonna go with the party
they agree with sixty-five percent of
the time that actually has a chance to
win ranked choice voting solves that
problem Warby Parker is offering a free
five day home try-on to give you the
opportunity to check out their glasses i
personally wear Warby Parker glasses
when I'm not wearing my contact lenses
and I also started with one of these
free at home try ons of five pairs of
glasses you can get your free home
try-on and support the david pakman show
at Warby Parker trial dot-com / TDPS I
don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home try-on I was
able to pick five pairs that i liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com / TDPS it costs nothing